thanks Amit and good morning to everyone
okay let's talk about obfuscation let's
not worry about the titles for now
okay so we know what program obfuscation
is by now
and we know what virtual Black Box
sophistication is defined by uhur Savi
and we have a lot of strong negative
results for it okay and there are only a
handful of positive results for very
limited functionalities like Point
functions
and their extensions unless you go to
idealized models okay
okay this is completely different for
indistinguishability obfuscation that
changed just last year it was defined
also by bigger Savi and we have the
first general purpose construction uh in
2013 and since then we have had a lot of
new constructions which improve upon the
original construction analyze the tech
models and so on
and there are many many applications
that use IO now
okay
um what is IO very quickly we say that
um
mechanism satisfies IO security if for
any two programs p and Q which are
functionally equivalent the obfuscation
of pay looks instinctual from that of
queue
okay and now the key property here is
that the two programs have to be
identical
and this is really the problem if you've
been paying attention for the last few
days
you realize that IO doesn't really give
you any hiding guarantees so it is very
hard to make sense of it like even if
you achieve what what can we do with it
and at the face of it it looks very
useless
but in this past two years we have seen
many many constructions which use i o
and Achieve new results
and uh all of the talks I see I see that
many of these constructions are very
very complex
and the reason is that it doesn't really
i o doesn't really hide anything so you
have to come up with new techniques to
hide the information you want that
you're utilizing in your program and
there are only very handful of
techniques like puncturing 2K Paradigm
and some complex combination of these
two
Okay so
this brings us to the question is there
a model of now we have IO
is there a model of IO that is slightly
more useful than IO which can simplify
our constructions for example
okay
and one such approach was for example
different input sophistication which is
also defined by Burger City where uh
instead of requiring the two programs p
and Q to be identical we slightly relax
the condition and require that the
obfuscation mechanism also maintains
indistinguishability even if the Pro 2
programs are not identical merely they
look identical so for any polynomial
time algorithm if it is hard to find
a differing input then the obfuscation
of two programs should look
indistinguishable
okay
but if the programs were fixed in
advance then clearly you cannot satisfy
this so you have to define the notion of
a sampler over programs
so we say that a sampling algorithm sem
for two programs p and Q it is a good
sampling algorithm or a different input
sampler
if for uh every Circuit of polynomial
size
for every set of efficient algorithms it
is hard to find a different input x to
the programs that were sampled by the
sampler
okay
so this is the notion of a different
input sampler and I want you to pay
attention to these two two entities here
the sampler has random coins R but the
same coins are not provided as a
auxiliary input to the to the attacking
algorithm so the sampler can choose to
Output any augular information and that
is the good information that uh
attacking circuit has to use to find a
different input
so this is the existing notion of Dio
and then Dio security says Dio first
question says that these two
distributions should look
computationally and distinguishable
where in addition to the obfuscation of
the programs
the distinction also gets this input the
auxiliary input
okay
this is the diu security requirement and
uh
once again
even if the sampler might have used very
different random coins to sample the two
programs p and Q that is not what the
distinction algorithm gets this input
okay this is a key point in this
definition and other than that uh we
have we have the usual correctness and
efficiency requirements that I'm not not
going to go into
okay
and as a Stefano brilliantly explained
explained yesterday uh for uh for
auxiliary input obfuscation this
auxiliary input is actually source of a
lot of troubles and gurgetel
demonstrated a concrete assumption on on
obfuscation such that if you believe
that assumption then you can actually
rule out the existence of di in
particular with respect to General
auxiliary input
and we have seen from many examples in
the past that auxiliary input can be a
source of lot of troubles in particular
Stephen was ruling out the existence of
diffie-hellman the ddh problem auxiliary
input DH problem if you give me bgb
obfuscation okay so if you believe in
obfuscation then you can formulate
assumptions which imply implausibility
of some other uh type assumptions
okay
so
this really brings us back to where we
were either we believe in IO and
continue with all these complex
constructions which is great of course
if you can do that but in certain
situations it is just not possible to do
so you really have to rely on Dio
so then what do we do with this
auxiliary input we can get rid of them
but in that case it's not clear whether
it is going to be any more useful than
IO
okay the other option is that you can
just complain that all of these negative
results they uh work with a very
contrived type of auxiliary information
but for your application maybe this
assumption still holds and it would work
until someone breaks it but you will
also end up with a disparate set of
assumptions for which there is no real
understanding of why it should be secure
so in particular it leaves the
possibility of finding a notion of
obfuscation wear which is concise enough
that you can study so that if you break
if you prove an implausible result for
that particular notion
you would hope that at least it will
expose some weaknesses in your
obfuscation mechanism rather than be an
artifact of your definition
okay
and this is where uh our work comes in
we try to look at how exactly the
auxiliary information is used in current
negative results and try to sort of
attack the problem at the root so that
hopefully uh there is no funny
interaction going on in between
auxiliary input and the execution of the
program which you can exploit to rule
out the rule out the existence of such
Dio okay and if you look at all these
negative results really
all of them work by keeping some kind of
secret and auxiliary information in
particular the work that was very
relevant to our work
in this work auxiliary information is
just an obfuscated code such that if I
give you the code it is not possible for
you to extract a different input to the
programs however it is enough for you to
distinguish
Okay so
and even if you look at all the previous
results in this direction like boil and
pass and bitansky at all they all work
by keeping some kind of secret
information in the in the obfuscated
code
so that is the first thing I want to
rule out and if I can rule that out
hopefully I'll end up with the notion
that is plausible and concise and is
still useful
okay so this is where publicon Dio comes
in it simply removes the ability to keep
any secrets in the auxiliary information
in particular whatever random coins the
sampler used to sample the two programs
that is the only auxiliary information
allowed to the uh to the attacking
algorithm and to the distinguisher and
the idea is that if the sampler itself
couldn't find two inputs which allow you
to distinguish between the two programs
uh then uh
if you can really distinguish between
the the challenge of first questions you
must somehow break off first question
rather than rely on using auxiliary
information
okay
so uh let me start by defining it as
before we will Define a different input
sampler but now it will be public coin
where we have the sampling algorithm as
before it's going to Output two circuits
p and Q
but there is no auxiliary information
anymore here instead the attacking
algorithm simply gets the coins of the
sampling algorithm and then we require
that even then it should be hard to find
such inputs one example would be for
example coordinate instant hash
functions if the sampling algorithm is
outputting programs which may have
different Behavior if you found
collisions
then so be it even the sampling
algorithm cannot find such an input so
uh yeah
so the a INR
in the previous case it was Z yeah so
instead of requiring this instead of
giving the randomness of sampler as
input it could have for example given
whatever auxiliary information Sam
outputs
no no for example if the Sam wanted it
could output won't be a function of r
right and there is no way to recover r
so it's strictly less because the the
okay clearly the attacker can depend on
the sampler
and if I give him R it has all the
information that the sampler has right
but if it was Z then sampler can keep
some secret coins from the attacking
algorithm so
okay so as before we have uh we have the
notion of public or differing input
sampler and now we say uh okay and I
already explained you this
so now the notion of publico and Dio it
is just the same as uh original uh
notion except that you are only working
with public coin different input
Samplers okay and in particular pay
attention to this part it is not Z
anymore the the differing uh the
algorithm to the distinguishing
algorithm gets the same coincidence
input as the sampler
sorry one thing in the previous the
definition
the adversity is still non-uniform yes
so earlier we said that the Z cannot
depend on the earth the auxiliary
information the original definition
of course yeah sampler is outputting z
right
so
we're supposed to do yeah
okay so essentially we're saying that
the semper doesn't know the point to us
right no in particular if you look at
the negative results
in those negative results if I tell you
all the coins that the sampler used to
to sample the auxiliary information you
would be able to just find a different
input and that is what I want to roll
out here
there's no point where the future
programs yes in your case the center
does it means yeah those results are not
allowed yeah
disease fully informative about the
Earth
no you don't know that if I give you a
compressing function of r
is no how is z more information I
processed R to get Z
yes sure okay
okay if you said auxiliary information
then I'll say yes
okay
okay and I just want to want to say a
few things that uh I in defining this
notion we are just following what has
been there before we are not doing
something new I mean we are doing
something new but uh we are driving uh
inspiration from previous works on this
as well so first of all as I said before
this notion is plausible because there
is no secrets in the auxiliary input so
none of the existing results work so
that's good so we have a plausible
motion first of all but why should we
believe it any more than uh just
assuming that it is good for your
distribution well for these
distributions as I said before there is
no real understanding whereas if you
look at so all of these negative results
they also have a consequence to
extraction assumptions like knowledge of
exponent assumptions or snarks and so on
so if you define an auxiliary input
version of these Notions
they will be affected also by the gjsw
result unless
you do what was done back in 92 and 2004
only allow Randomness as the auxiliary
information for that there are no texts
for that there are no impossible
impossibility results and this
assumption has been there for a long
time it has been analyzed so we are in
good shoes we
if you
prove implausible results for public or
ndio our hope is really that you will
expose some weaknesses in the
obfuscation mechanism rather than just
exploiting the definition of
uh information out there okay so
and it is also better than assuming
benign distribution so you cannot if you
just assume a uniform distribution over
uh over auxiliary information that's
also not okay
because it might still be possible to
keep secrets which will allow you to
which will allow the sampler to somehow
find a differing input whereas the this
uh whereas the distinction algorithm
might not be able to exploit such a such
an input so you really need to rule out
the possibility of any Secret Coins
rather than just assuming benign
distribution which look harmless
okay
so now you have this notion the next
question is too weak by requiring the
the information to be public coin maybe
in your hybrid arguments you won't be
able to use it anymore
okay
so what we can show is that you can
recover the bootstrapping theorem that
has been there for Dio
in particular if you give me a publicon
Dio for nc1 and fully homophic
encryption and its narcs then I can give
you succinct public coin Dio for Turing
machines and I don't have to assume any
kind of bound on the on the input length
and
as I pointed out before all of these
negative results about the Dio they also
impact extractability assumptions such
as snarks so for this result it is very
important that we
only work with the public coin
formulation of snark
where luxury information is is just the
randomness of the of the adversary
so the only candidate for such a
construction is mikali CS proof so this
result has to assume that megalisius
proves uh are secure
okay
Now using the first result I can also
give you succinct functional encryption
for Turing machines now these things are
already known let me tell you right but
not for tuning machines with unbounded
input but my goal here is it is only
selectively secure but my goal here is
not to provide the feasibility result
but just to show that publico and Dio is
actually useful more than you would
think
it's not completely useless because it
really looks like if the auxiliary
information is just random uniformly
random string that has no secrets how
can you use it it's like having no
auxiliary input at all so
this notion still implies are you all
right yes of course yeah because there
are no different inputs
useful is also useful so the question is
is a proof set so even for this second
result is the proof simpler or then you
you kind of skip some step or first of
all you don't have this result if you
don't assume uh Dio some form of Dio
not anymore okay okay so apparently
there is some new result which hopefully
gets you this but yes this is
simpler also yes that is also true
one of the two things is true okay so
there is a quantitative aspect of the
leg of the sub-exponential security
versus polynomial security so for
publico in dio we only need polynomial
security whereas all of the recent
techniques that exploit the you know in
this in this domain they all rely on
sub-exponential i o so it's kind of like
what do you prefer sub-exponential
one-way function or polynomial time to
absorb permutation right in the old days
that's an aesthetic choice but they're
technically in comparable assumption
it's not certainly not worse
okay and the construction is also much
simpler but it is more complex than the
previous constructions which are only
for circuits because it the auxiliary
information is public coin so you really
have to be more careful in hybrids my
question is even for things which were
known from here I I'm saying an example
where the a year would shape at one of
them yes
you will see so for example I'll show
you uh a non non-blackbox simulation
technique where you would see I'll just
simply replace the universal argument
with the obfuscation of a turing machine
and I'll just hide some information and
this information is never seen if you
cannot find collisions in the hash
function whereas with IO I cannot do
that
okay so this is what I was mentioning
that you can go all the way to
concurrency knowledge using this result
we can get fully concurrent zero
knowledge also so and it is a new
non-blackbooks technique which simply
exploits uh obfuscation and instead of
doing Universal arguments
so let me talk a little bit about the
construction for Turing machines and
this is again just to give you a flavor
of how the construction would go and how
the proof might go I will not go into
too much detail but just to give you a
flavor of why public coin is still
sufficient
okay so everybody knows what functional
encryption is so I'm not going to go
into that
we are only going to work with Selective
security so the adversary will announce
the two strings x0 and X1 in the
beginning and later on he will ask for
keys for Turing machines okay and
because we are dealing with Turing
machines and there is no uprighty fixed
bound on on size of x0 and X1
so unlike previous techniques x0. next
one cannot go into the public parameters
so we have to be careful about that do
you have a question
this is the definition of
indistinguishability based functional
encryption for Turing machines
say it again sorry like selective secure
yeah with Selective security yes
your diagram here with a selected what's
selected
the the bits that will be encrypted uh
have been announced in the beginning
even before you see public parameters
okay so the construction the setup we
are going to have first of all three
public keys so in the previous
constructions you saw two public keys
where you exploited two key Paradigm but
here we need three public keys because
we'll have to extract a string which
finds collisions in the hash function
that is what pk3 is for
okay we will have two strings Alpha and
Alpha two each one of them is a
commitment to zero string fresh
commitment to zero string
and then as before we will have a hash
function and a CRS for music proofs
the master secret key is going to be the
secret key for the first public key
what about encryption first of all you
will encrypt us before under the first
two public Keys the same value X
and then under C3 you will encrypt
everything you have known so far in
particular you'll encrypt the value X
and the randomness that you used in the
first two encryption and don't worry
about the format for now
okay and then you will give a Music
proof about the correctness of C1 C2 and
C3
so what will you prove so here is the
ciphertext from the previous slide
you will prove that there is Randomness
R3 and a string a of this of this format
where
first of all is encrypted under C3
and second in c1c to either you're
encrypting the same value
or if you are not encrypting the same
value then the hash of both of these
values appears in alpha alpha 1 and
Alpha 2. so alpha 1 is is a commitment
to Hash of X1 and Alpha 2 is a
commitment to Hash of X2
um it's in the public parameters
okay
what about Q generation it's simple as
you would expect you will just give an
obfuscation of a program which
um
oh human and U2 yeah that's just a
Randomness for for you and Alpha two
okay
yeah don't focus on literals and
chair because it it's slightly more
useful when you're proving so I don't
have to necessarily bind Alpha into X1
and Alpha 2 to X2 if I do it this way
that's why I'm not setting J equals to I
but
yeah one of them is a commitment to X1
and the other one is equivalent to x two
so
actually
a little I lost track so X1 and X2 are
the two strings announced in the
beginning for which we are proving
security it's selectively secure so
right
presumably you're going to use it not
only in that game where X1 and X2 right
so an honest encrypter will never have
to worry about this because he's always
encrypting the same values
right
sure are not Quantified outside the
proof there's
they're under the existential quantifier
right right I mean X1 next to exists
exists because encryption is binding and
the format has been fixed here so the
statement is also well defined NP
statement is also not dependent on
public parameters necessarily right
right yeah properly
okay key generation is simply an
obfuscation of a program which evaluates
the turing machine after decrypting C1
but before that we'll just verify that
the proof is correct and here we're just
going to use public or India for Turing
machines okay so here's the program
and decryption is you simply run this
program on the safer text
okay so here is a high level idea of
proof sketch yes sorry
until you're going too fast here oh okay
well the reason is that the construction
is very very similar to previous
constructions the key point is this hash
function and pk3
so um
other than that previous constructions
so for example GTH RSW where you use
statistically sound music where there is
only one theorem for which this music is
false you're saying
there was a simple construction no no
okay let's step back no no let's step
back let's step back for ghrsw
there was a construction for functional
encryption for circuits not for Turing
machines okay so here I'm clearly
getting something more okay but
obviously I have to pay somewhere right
no in fact the proof techniques by
itself fails and and you have to rely on
because you have to rely on public or
ndio yeah
um but the ideas for switching from sk1
to sk2 and those ideas are very similar
so that's why I'm going to first I guess
um
okay so here are the public parameters
uh this is how encryption looked like
and this is what the secret key looked
like okay and we are going to go from
encryption of X1 to encryption of X2 to
prove security everything else will
remain the same and for all Turing
machines m m of X1 is going to be equal
to M of X2 so in the first part I'm
going to change Alpha final Alpha 2. in
particular I know X1 x2 in the beginning
so I can set alpha 1 to be a commitment
of hash of X1 and Alpha 2 to be a
commitment of hash of X2 and this change
looks indistinguishable
and in particular once I have made this
change I can if I wanted to prove a
quote-unquote fals a statement it's not
really false because I know Witness
but I can get away with encrypting two
different values
so the proof is statistically sound
okay so in the second part I'm going to
change X1 to X2
as a result this is also going to change
my witness and this is going to change
C3 also my encryption okay
um before I do that oops
but the good part is that we can rely on
a strong non-interactive witness
instinctivity so even if there is only
one witness
because the statements look
indistinguishable this part is also this
this part is also easily acute okay
nothing new here
great
yeah is still true
because I will use I will use the fact
that Alpha One is indeed a commitment to
Hash of X1 and Alpha 2 to Hash of X2 but
what is the five how to generate five
what is
X2 along with the randomness used to
yeah the first that's the first thing I
did yeah
okay and now I'm going to switch sk1 to
sk2
this is okay because M of X1 is equal to
M of X2 and in particular this is where
the hash function is being used in
particular if there is an adversary who
can distinguish this change then you can
extract a cipher text
which will have this particular
structure it will have C1 C2 and C3 and
the proof will be correct
so if you did not encrypt either x 1
here or X2 here or any value different
from X1 and X2
then it must imply that hash of one of
those two strings
is committed in Alpha One or Alpha 2.
but I already fixed alpha alpha one
alpha 2 to Hash of X1 and hash of X2 and
since one of these two values is at
least different from both X1 and X2 I
would have found a collision and I can
extract such a collision because I know
secret key for pk3 that was the entire
role of pk3
okay
now let me give you another example is
that okay or
that's all okay very quickly
so let me just quickly show you what how
I can avoid Universal arguments in
barack's protocol which is a straight
line zero knowledge
and not not the concurrency knowledge
but only the straight lines are on which
part okay so very quickly you have
proven very far where you have the first
Preamble a three rounds with the hash
function is sent by the verifier the
Brewer will commit to some random string
or zero and the verify will respond with
r and then they run an encrypted
Universal argument where the proven
proves that it knows a program which
could have predicted r
and then in the end there's a witness
instinctual proof about X
or success in encrypted argument
and and your proves uh simulation by
just using V starsc code
now this is the part I want to remove
and as I was saying earlier you can
simply replace it by the first question
of the following turing machine it
accepts as input a program and all the
witnesses all the random strings and
everything that you were going to use in
the encrypted Universal argument
and it verifies all of those things that
you were proving in the encrypted your
Arc and if so then it will output the
secret and now you can see uh they are
getting that there is a secret value m
right and there are no two key Paradigm
there is no functioning going on here
yeah
discussion is a universal argument
no this is an
assistant which accepts a program as
input verifies
a generic way to build Universal
arguments
I haven't thought about that
because I mean there might be things
like extraction and so on so if you so
for soundness we do rely on Dio property
so then maybe something like that will
show up in the proof
but here it's okay because we are only
relying on uh we are using di only for
soundness not for zero knowledge
okay
that's a little tricky to see but the
only thing in the end uh so for this
part to work right you only need to
prove that you cannot extract a witness
which will allow you to learn an m and
for that all that really matters is that
this uh part you cannot succeed in this
part but even uh if you had a witness to
X you will never be able to succeed in
this part that you can just derive from
from drugs protocol as long as H is
Collision resistant
okay and that only relies on the public
coin property so no matter what secret
you know about the verifier you can
still conclude this and therefore you
can rely on this
Universal
your knowledge proofs with diffuse pcbio
and you no longer have the balance
okay so as I was saying uh again to
evgeny I guess this is indistinguishable
from from a dummy program which simply
output spot right and um and that and
then it will have no information about M
and therefore you can prove soundness
okay
so again key points here uh for this
construction to work you must use Turing
machines a first question for Turing
machines because there is no priority
bound on how big we start is
uh public ndio is sufficient and you
actually get an explicit simulator which
is unlike uh knowledge of exponent based
assumption constructions where you only
get an existential result but you don't
get an actual simulator that you can run
but here you do get a simulator
okay
only for soundness
and finally this simple protocol does
not give you concurrency knowledge but
it is actually possible to make it
concurrence your knowledge based on
these techniques
and and finally uh very recently uh
Chung Lin and pass they do get
concurrency knowledge under some
exponential i o
so
constant run concrete
you don't need some exponential okay
so
great
protocol that I told you and the
simulator because you can instead of
using restarts code you could have just
but that that does not extend because
the running time keeps increasing so it
will become exponential very quickly so
you have to rely on DJs Oracle that once
you have extracted a tripod you never
extract it again so you commit Oracle
program so the point of the bullet is
that it can be extended yes no it
depends on how you say the technique can
be extended but that particular protocol
and the simulator does not extend too
yes
this is not an open problem right
yeah all right okay well it was until I
guess
this
okay let's collapse
foreign